big tech has its eyes set on your wallet
Apple has a credit card Facebook is
trying to introduce its own currency and
Google has plans to offer checking
accounts to users of its digital wallet
in 2020 you can do a lot with a wallet
in your phone like boarding a train or
so tech firms are offering services that
are usually associated with banks but
they're doing it differently it's really
about data when a company like Apple or
Google processes a payment for you they
find out a lot about you they know what
you bought where you bought it what time
of the day or what day of the month
you're likely to spend money and that's
really valuable information for
advertisers also banking is another way
for tech firms to draw customers further
into their universes so Facebook started
out as a way to talk to your friends and
then became a place you've shared baby
photos with your grandparents and now
you can shop on Facebook properties you
can message Instagram whatsapp Amazon is
the same way it started out as a big
store and now they make home speakers
they make original movies and television
shows so these companies all started off
with one thing and they're adding more
things around it and Finance is kind of
the last frontier as more people change
their banking habits tech companies say
they can bring something to the table
google says it will build helpful tools
while relying on partnerships to
navigate the financial world for its
part Apple promises to eliminate fees
for its credit card and give you cash
back instantly and the Apple pay app
will have charts that help users track
their buying habits meanwhile the
Facebook pact
liebherr Association says that using a
blockchain to process transactions could
make cross-border payments cheaper and
faster the company says it's planned
cryptocurrency Libre could provide
banking services for billions of people
that plan is faced headwinds several
early partners dropped from the project
and US Fed Chairman Jerome Powell raised
concerns with the plan saying that
Facebook's size could make Libra
immediately systemic ly important if
that size is on display in the other
services - according to projections from
Juniper research Google pay is on track
to have 100 million users worldwide in
20
by that time Apple pay could have 227
million users both would be huge
increases from 2018 these tech companies
are already really big and some
regulators think too big
several US regulatory bodies already
have antitrust investigations into
Google Apple Facebook and other big
companies their push into banking could
sharpen those concerns and public trust
is an issue too and the poll from
McKinsey and company suggests that a
slight majority of respondents would
trust Google and Apple to handle their
finances but Facebook fared less well
some people are already wary of giving
tech companies access to their location
and their photos financial data is just
way more personal more concerns of a
privacy and power will be on display as
tech firms get into finance the data are
valuable and increasingly they're in the
hands of a few tech companies
[Music]